[Music]
in america for the last 24 months
lots of people have lived in such a
jacked up
anxiety-ridden
semi-rage
state of mind
that to come back down off of all of
those hormones and proteins
and be calm again is kind of a weird
thing
might be a good new year's resolution by
the way
turn off the television
the news channels anyway
uh unplug or largely unplug from social
media
and back away from the manure
if you're pouring that much manure into
your brain your brain is going to turn
into manure
i knew i had a problem when i actually
violated one of my lifelong rules one of
my rules is don't ever read the comments
after any article
if you want to know why some species eat
their young you can tell
by reading the comments after the
articles these are some of the dumbest
human beings on the planet
and some of the meanest too
any article on anything
and i knew it was time for me to just
back away
from the screen
because you get in jacked up mode
because here's the thing dr delany talks
about this all the time facts are your
friends
and when your brain is jacked up like
that
on fear
and rage
you've been doing all the coveted fear
porn over and over death you're going to
die you're going to die you're going to
die you're going to die
and your brain gets jacked up
to the point that your critical thinking
skills just disappear
none of us
do good critical long-term thinking
when we were really angry or really
afraid
your brain doesn't work that way
if you're standing near the street and a
car at 60 miles an hour swerves towards
you
your brain is designed to scream at you
get out of the way
not to analyze the possible impact of a
2019 escalade on my hip
you don't have time to do all of these
discussions in your head just move
your brain is primitive and is designed
to throw you out of the way
of danger not to have a critical
thinking discussion about it
or what i should have said in that
argument
get out of the way and so your brain
shuts down its ability to do critical
thinking when you're freaked out
and when you're in trauma like that the
lonely teaches us and it's been a really
good lesson i've enjoyed learning it
myself
that we when we're in trauma like that
we have to force ourselves into higher
thinking
we have to say facts
are my friends what are the
facts
what's really happening what do you see
with your eyes
do you see people falling down dead all
around you
what are you really seeing with your
eyes
what is the actual facts
not what someone says is science not
what someone says
is
their political stance on something what
are the actual
facts
now when those occur
then you will act on those
but until then you need to get about
your business of having a life
you need to move on
and you need to put
stupid people
and stupid processes
and stupid conclusions
that were emotion based in your rear
view mirror
nothing wrong with emotions until they
start running your life
and we've got a whole generation or two
that was raised thinking their feelings
are valid
your feelings aren't valid they're
feelings
it's valid to have feelings but it is
not valid to make decisions based on
your feelings that's what children do
children do what feels good
adults
use higher thinking skills devise a plan
and follow it
and we follow it based on the facts that
we see in front of us
what is the real world
what actually has happened
not what someone says might happen
not what someone thinks is going to
happen
not what you worry about at 2 o'clock in
the morning as your brain dreams up all
of these bizarre freaking scenarios
about your life and don't we all do that
we do
facts are your friends
when you're facing this stuff
we started telling you that with the
covet shutdown and the quarantine
almost two years ago
we started telling you that
you know i had just gotten back from a
trip to australia when covet hit and we
went into quarantine
sharon and i spent a month in australia
our first trip over there we loved
australia was fabulous and if you recall
the beginning of 2020 there were massive
fires in australia
if you were to watch the news in america
you would have thought the entire
continent of australia was on fire
we were there a month
and had you know had did you know went
to one area where the fires had been
and the uh the vegetation was already
starting to grow back
in those areas beautiful green valley
but the fires were real and they were
devastating and i'm not saying they're
they weren't horrible they were but they
they did not cover the entire continent
of australia
and we actually had
several people of course this is
pre-covered right the early early early
days of cove there were a few people in
the
airports with masks in those days but
very few
and we had lots of people in australia
tell us say hey would you please tell
americans that the entire continent did
not burn down because apparently
americans based on what they saw on fox
and cnn decided that australia was a
black charred mess not to go
and tourism was way down
because of the perception
of the fires
not the reality
the reality was a very small percentage
of the continent was actually affected
now the percentage that was affected was
a big problem and it was devastating i'm
not not saying that wasn't so but the
difference is what are the facts
versus what you saw on the news
because what you read in the newspaper
if anybody does still do that
what you read on some website
and what is the truth is very seldom the
same thing
what you see in a news report is so
jacked up
we got two three inches of snow today in
nashville and you would think according
to the news that it is 17 feet deep out
here
the facts are
that people in the south can't drive in
the snow so you probably should stay
home
but it's not knee deep
barely over the soles of your shoes
and if you have a four-wheel drive and
go slow you're gonna be just fine
and consequently i've been at work all
day so i'm not and i'm not shaming you
if you're not at work today in nashville
that's okay it's fine i understand i got
a bunch of our folks on our team didn't
come in and i'm not mad at them or
anything like that they if they can't
drive in the snow they shouldn't do it
but if you were to watch the news is my
point
according to the these newscasts these
weather forecasters sound like a beagle
chasing a rabbit
you would think
i have read articles written about dave
ramsey
that i don't even understand
how did you where did you get that
it has nothing to do with anything that
is me
nothing to do
that didn't happen
it just didn't occur
somebody just made it up
and you know it's amazing to me okay so
the point is folks don't make your
financial plan like our last caller in
that last segment
based on your fears
fears aren't facts
analyze the fearful situation and figure
out how much of it is actually factual
use your adult higher thinking skills
is the is the snow really 17 feet deep
is it really
this is the ramsey show